[Music]
blehh said of the poor in spirit for
theirs is the kingdom of heaven blessed
are those who mourn for they will be
comforted blessed are the meek that they
will inherit the earth blessed are those
who hunger and thirst for righteousness
for they will be filled blessed are the
merciful for they will be shown mercy
blessed are the pure in heart for they
will see God blessed are the peacemakers
for they will be called children of God
blessed are those who are persecuted
because of righteousness for theirs is
the kingdom of heaven blessed are you
when people insult you persecute you and
falsely say all kinds of evil against
you because of me rejoice and be glad
because great is your reward in heaven
for in the same way they persecuted the
prophets who were before you you are the
salt of the earth but if the salt loses
its saltiness how can it be made salty
again
it is no longer good for anything except
to be thrown out and trampled underfoot
[Music]
you are the light of the world
a town built on a hill cannot be hidden
neither do people light a lamp and put
it under a bowl instead they put it on
its stand and it gives light to tell
everyone in the house in the same way
let your light shine before others that
they may see your good deeds and glorify
your father in it do not think that I
have come to abolish the law or the
prophets I've not come to abolish them
but to fulfill
for truly I tell you until heaven and
earth disappear
not the smallest letter not the least
stroke of a pen will by any means
disappear from the law until everything
as a compression
[Music]
therefore anyone who sits aside one of
the least of these commands and teaches
others accordingly will be called least
in the kingdom of heaven but whoever
practices and teaches these commands
will be called great in the kingdom of
heaven but I tell you that unless your
righteousness surpasses that of the
Pharisees and the teachers of the law
you will certainly not enter the kingdom
of heaven you heard that it was said to
the people long ago you shall not murder
and anyone who murders will be subject
to judgment
but I tell you that anyone who is angry
with a brother or sister will be subject
to judgment
again anyone who says to a brother or
sister raka is answerable to the court
and anyone who says you fool will be in
danger of the fire of hell therefore if
you are offering your gift of the altar
and there remember that your brother or
sister has something against you leave
your gift there in front of you first go
and be reconciled to them then
settle matters quickly with your
adversary who is taking you to court do
it while you're still together away or
your adversary may hand you over to the
judge and the judge may have you over to
the officer and you may be thrown into
prison truly I tell you you will not get
out until you have paid the last penny
[Music]
you have heard that it was said you
shall not commit adultery but I tell you
that anyone who looks at a woman
lustfully has already committed adultery
with her in his heart if your right eye
causes you to stumble gouge it out and
throw it away it is better for you to
lose one part of your body than for your
whole body to be thrown into hell and if
your right hand causes you to stumble
cut it off and throw it away it is
better for you to lose one part of your
body than for your whole body to go into
hell it has been said anyone who
divorces his wife must give her a
certificate of do
but I tell you that anyone who divorces
his wife except for sexual immorality
makes her the victim of adultery and
anyone who marries a divorced woman
commits adultery again you have heard
that it was said to the people long ago
do not break your oath but fulfill to
the Lord the oaths you have made but I
tell you do not swear an oath at all
either by heaven for it is God's throne
who or by the earth for it is his
footstool or by Jerusalem for it is the
city of the Great King
I do not swear by your head for you
cannot make even one hair white or black
all you need to say is simply yes or no
anything beyond this comes from the evil
one you have heard that it was said I
for eye and tooth for tooth but I tell
you do not resist an evil person
if anyone slaps you on the right cheek
turn to that the other jingles and if
anyone wants to sue you and take your
shirt
hand over your coat as well if anyone
forces you to go one mile go with them
two miles give to the one who passes you
and do not turn away for the one who
wants to borrow
you have heard that it was said love
your neighbor and hate your enemy but I
tell you love your enemies and pray for
those who persecute you that you may be
children of your father in heaven
he causes his Sun to rise of the evil
and the good and sends rain on the
righteous and the unrighteous if you
love those who love you what reward will
you give are not even the tax collectors
doing that but if you greet only your
own people what are you doing more than
others do not even pagans do that
as your heavenly Father is perfect be
careful not to practice your
righteousness in front of others to be
seen by them if you do you will have no
reward from your father in heaven so
when you give to the needy do not
announce it with profits as the
hypocrites do in the synagogues and on
the streets to be honored by others
truly I tell you they have received
their reward in full but when you give
to the needy do not let your left hand
know what your right hand is doing so
that your giving may be in secret then
your father who sees what is done in
secret will reward you and when you pray
do not be like the hypocrites for they
love to pray standing in the synagogues
and on the street corners to be seen
forever
truly I tell you they have received
their reward in full but when you pray
go into your room close the door and
pray to your father who is unseen
then your father who sees what is done
in secret will reward you and when you
pray do not keep on babbling like pagans
for they think they'll be heard because
of their many words do not be like them
for your father knows what you need
before you ask you this thing is how you
should pray our Father in heaven
hallowed be your name your kingdom come
your will be done on earth as it is in
heaven
give us today our daily bread
and forgive us our debts as we also have
forgiven our debtors
and lead us not into temptation but
deliver
[Music]
if you forgive other people when they
sin against you your heavenly Father
will also forgive you
but if you do not forgive others their
sins your father will not forgive your
sins when you fast do not look sullen as
the hypocrites do
but they disfigure their faces to show
others they are fasting truly I tell you
they have received their reward in full
but when you fast put oil on your head
and wash your face so that it will not
be obvious to others that you're fasting
but only to your father who is unseen
and your father who sees what is done in
secret will reward you
do not store up for yourselves treasures
on earth where moths and vermin destroy
and where thieves break in and steal
that's tone up for yourselves treasures
in heaven
we're moths and Berland are not
destroyed we're thieves do not break in
and steal for where your treasure is
there your heart will people say
the eye is the lamp of the body if your
eyes are healthy your whole body will be
for the life
but if your eyes are unhealthy your
whole body will be full of darkness
if they're the light within you is
darkness how great is that darkness no
one can serve two masters either you
will hate the one and love the other or
you will be devoted to the one that
despise the other you cannot serve both
God and money therefore I tell you
they're not worried about your life what
you will eat or drink or about your body
what you will wear is not life more than
food and the body more than clothes look
at the birds of the air they do not sow
or reap or store away in barns and yet
your heavenly Father feeds them by you
not much more valuable
can any one of you by worrying at a
single how do you live
and why do you worry about clothes see
how the flowers of the field grow they
do not labor or spin yet I tell you that
not even Solomon in all his splendor was
dressed like one of these and if that is
how God clothes the grass of the field
which is here today and tomorrow is
thrown into the fire will he not much
more clothe you you
Cinda know why I said what shall we eat
or what shall we drink or what shall we
wear for the pagans run after all these
things and your heavenly Father knows
that you need them
the seek first his kingdom and his
righteousness and all these things will
be given to you as well therefore do not
worry about
the tomorrow will worry about itself
each day as a [ __ ] trouble of its own
[Music]
do not judge or you too will be judged
for in the same way as you judge others
you will be judged and with the measure
you use it will be bashful to you why do
you look at the speck of sawdust in your
brother's eye and pay no attention to
the plank in your own eye and when you
say to your brother let me take the
speck out of your eye when all the time
there is a plank in your own eye
you hypocrite first take the plank out
of your own eye and then you will see
clearly to remove the speck from your
brother's eye
do not give down what is sacred
do not throw your pearls apiece if you
do they make trample them under their
feet and turn
pieces
[Music]
ass and they will be given to you seek
and you are find knock and the door will
be open to you that everyone who asks
receives the one who seeks finds and to
the one who knows the door will be
opened
which of you if your son asks for bread
will give him a stone or if he asks for
a fish will give him a snake if you then
though you are evil know how to give
good gifts to your children how much
more will your Father in Heaven give
good gifts to those who ask him
so in everything do to others what you
would have them do to you this sums up
the law and the prophets enter through
the narrow gate for wide is the gate and
broad is the road that leads to
destruction and many enter through it
but small is the gate and narrow the
road that leads to life and only a few
find it watch out for false prophets
they come to you in sheep's clothing but
inwardly they are ferocious wolves by
their fruit you will recognize them do
people pick grapes from thornbushes or
figs from thistles likewise every good
tree bears good fruit but a bad tree
Bears bad fruit a good tree cannot bear
bad fruit and a bad tree cannot bear
good fruit every tree that does not bear
good fruit is cut down and thrown into
the fire thus by their fruit you will
recognize them not everyone who says to
me Lord Lord will enter the kingdom of
heaven but everyone who does the will of
my father who is
many will say to me on that day Lord
Lord did we not prophesy in your name
and in your name drive out demons and in
your name perform many miracles
and I tell her
I never knew you away from me you
evildoers therefore everyone who hears
these words of mine and puts them into
practice is like a wise man who built
his house on the rain came down the
streams rose and the winds blew and beat
against that house yet it did not fall
because it had its foundation
but everyone who hears these words of
mine and does not put them into practice
is like a foolish man who built his
house on sand
the rain came down the streams rose and
the winds blew and beat against that
house and it fell with a great crash
when Jesus had finished saying these
things the crowds were amazed as his
teaching because he taught as one who
had Authority not as their teachers
[Music]
[Music]
you